congratulations on even making it to
survivor 41 the hardest season ever of
survivor so congratulations on that
how are you feeling today with the
emotions so raw and it's it's pretty
fresh i can imagine
you know there's a ton of emotions from
disappointment from frustration to anger
to just being grateful to being out
there i mean it's it's all ends of the
spectrum and i think that last night was
actually really helpful for me was
therapeutic because you saw how crazy it
was how it did not make sense you heard
lyanna say this is idiotic you heard
evie be like what are we doing you saw
tiffany just be like i can't think
straight which is obviously what
happened because why would you do that
so it's it a little bit of vindication
after that but i think that i don't want
to overshadow the whole arc and saying
what an incredible experience just to be
out there you learn so much about
yourself you learn um it just
this incredible adventure that just kind
of strips you down to your core is
really
pretty awesome and i i was kind of a
naysayer heading into that being like oh
yeah jeff always says that but it really
does strip you down it really teaches
you who you are as a person and really
uh is just incredible
100 and i yeah i think you talked about
the chaotic energy you also you know
mentioned just
the blind side and i think as someone
who was watching i was like what like
this was not in the course of action um
did you feel that way like did you feel
like it was totally unexpected
oh yeah it was 100 a total blind side
and for all future survivor players out
there if jeff is ever talking to you
about your personal life like how do you
get like this i remember sitting there
thinking huh this is cool but why is
jeff paying so much attention to me i'm
not up tonight
ding ding ding you are in trouble and
you know i i remember the first tribal
council thinking jeff you're giving it
away it's abraham don't say that thing
that's like why didn't i catch on and
say you should be worried um but yeah
complete blind side and what you're
never safe in survivor if you think
you're safe that's when you know you're
in trouble but
i did feel that you know
it was going to be between xander and
between tiffany i thought those were the
two options i felt liana and myself were
honestly the most safe out of anyone
because um i did have a sneaking
suspicion that there was a female
alliance going on but if there is a
female alliance you have to get
alexander he's the one with all the
power that he can't use so i'm sitting
pretty and there you go as you watch me
going out
the stress of it all i was so shocked um
you did mention the two targets tiffany
and xander and i did want to ask you
what do you think it says about
tiffany's social game even though there
was a little bit of chaotic energy what
does it say about her social game that
she was able to convince her fellow
female alliance to vote you out yeah so
i think that there's an underlying
message here that is most important i
think that the girls came in
specifically evie saying i want a
woman's alliance there hasn't been a
female winner in so long i want this
above all else because the and that ran
so deep and i think that that was
something that we needed to pick up on
because i i truly believe this you saw
tiffany's meltdown and yeah sure edit
doesn't show you anything but you saw
her saying i can't think through this
and you know that's a liability if you
have someone in your alliance that
cannot think through it and i love
tiffany to death but she was a physical
liability in that challenge and she she
is athletic it's just that one challenge
she said she could do a balance beam
didn't exactly happen but she was a
physical liability there and then she
was kind of an emotional liability there
and so
i think that what superseded this was
that desire to keep together a woman's
alliance and i'll be the first to say
the end all be
all in survivor is your alliance so i
get keeping an alliance strong but i
have a real hard time understanding how
that kept the alliance strong when you
kept tiffany and you kept xander because
if it is an all woman's alliance you
gotta boot xander so
what and the key that i will also add is
that evie was at that truck when she got
back she had five minutes it was five
minutes i didn't even get a one-on-one
conversation with her so in five minutes
she had to scramble and try and be the
voice of reason i mean they should have
done a 2-1 split if they wanted to do it
to prevent to flush an idle if they
worry about that but i think in that
moment it was so pushed for time in the
sense of five minutes that ebby just had
to say fine this works you know it's
really in all girls lines devotee that's
fine but really that's so unfortunate
because when you think about it there's
only four people back at camp only three
people had votes so with all these
advantages he can vote he can't vote if
you don't have a primary vote you can't
use your shot in the dark it was so
convoluted it became a game of russian
roulette
totally and i think you saying that
there was only five minutes between when
evie hit the beach and then you guys
were off to tribal it illuminates so
much it makes a lot of sense zander you
mentioned is playing the game really
hard which we love to see as fans but
it's there's just a lot happening um i
wanted to ask you do you think he will
be able you know he survived this one
tribal do you think he's next on the
chopping block what do you think is that
going to help or hinder him how he's
playing the game
yeah i think definitely he's next on the
chopping block if this woman's alliance
is that strong you know the whole issue
is the risk that the girls took is when
is the idol gonna be activated and
that's why he needed to go because you
don't know could it be the next
challenge could it be ten challenges you
have no clue and that's a risk eliminate
the risk um so yeah i definitely think
that he's you know
i'll say this i would say normally you
know when you get a 3-1 split someone
wants to pull in the one but in this
case the women are so dead set on this
woman's alliance as they've just proven
tiffany
we're working with you regardless of how
irrational regardless of how leona said
this is idiotic
we're going to go with idiotic because
that is what we're doing so i do think
that xander uh could find himself in a
tight spot we'll have to see
100 and i mean i wanted to ask you too
something that struck me right at the
end of tribal was when xander was
sitting you know when he was looking
around the women and said wow that was
really hard and so a few of us watching
it looked like he had an inkling of what
was going on so do you feel like he was
aware that you were going home
yeah i do and i i'll say this i think
that probably evie kind of tipped him
off so that evie would not feel like she
was alienated because if she knew i was
going home then i think she needed to
kind of calm him down i do think that
you know people would ask why didn't i
throw xander under the bus and just be
like let's get alexander that's a great
question but i think that you have to
understand is that loyalty in the game
is important and so
me having this thing with evie even if i
thought evie was with the girls by all
of a sudden flipping on xander evie
might say whoa this guy is totally
unloyal you know he's acting you know
like he is playing so hard and so he's
going for it so i did not really think
that that would be an option at that
point but i do think that um evie was
very
smart to say
this plan is going to crap i've got to
you know clue him in because you saw
evie at the trucks telling desean
everything about xander that's because
she thought xander was going she did not
think xander was going to be there so
who cares if she tells xander's secrets
yeah 100 it seemed like there was a lot
of ducks in the row there going on um i
wanted to ask you too you know
this is such an incredible season and
we as survivor fans have been kind of
stifled for so long due to the pandemic
so i wanted to ask you like what was it
just like being on the beach
meeting jeff getting to talk to jeff
even though he kind of like like you
said he was spending a lot of time on
you and you should have been tipped off
but like just explain the experience for
us because i i can't imagine how
wonderful it was for you yeah you know i
was cast before covet even started and
so we were a couple days out from flying
out and i didn't think i almost wasn't
able to go then it's my schedule you
know it fell through i didn't know if it
was going to happen didn't know if i
could go it finally went you know that
that year actually i think kind of
simmered some of my excitement down
which was good um but finally being out
there after the quarantine after
everything and starting on that barge
you just felt the excitement and i'm
sure it's always exciting but the the
crew it was palpable being like we're
finally here finally able to do this and
i think that in general survivor you
know you see all the action-packed
challenges on the screen but what really
i remember from being out there is just
the day-to-day life of getting to know
people that raw human connection
learning about each other learning about
your differences learning about your
similarities um taking aqua dumps
together which if you want to get to
know people really well you gotta [ __ ]
with them um so just those experiences
is what i really take away from it and i
think one of the what really wasn't
evident on the edit is how close the
yaasa tribe was
especially the five of us another kind
of insider thing that wasn't shown first
week is that it was really five versus
one from day one poor abraham we got
done with the sweat challenge he took
our flint and he broke it in half and we
didn't have fire and i mean xander and i
were furious
and there was no really remorse or
anything great guy outside of the game
but he just didn't gel with us so from
day one it had been the five of us and
we just i mean we just enjoyed each
other we're gonna be lifelong friends
and that's something that is really
invaluable and was really cool but at
the same time i will also say it was
probably a detriment to our game because
i think when there's conflict that's
really easy to put people against each
other 100
um i wanted to ask you two you know
this game is so hard without the
accelerated timeline you guys are on and
no food and no rice like this is again
being billed as the hardest season of
survivor ever so what was the hardest
part for you
yeah so the hardest part so typically
the third person goes out on day nine or
day ten and this was day five and i
think when you have so many advantages
so many twists
when you can barely keep the facts
straight and then when you have you
remove someone on a five-person tribe to
go on a trek
and everyone's trying to keep track of
votes you don't really know how the shot
in the dark actually works you're trying
to keep track of he has a vote he
doesn't have a vote he has an extra vote
but he doesn't have a primary vote that
means he can't use this shot in the dark
i mean our heads were spinning and so i
actually
you know evie and i were following i
feel bad for tiffany because i get what
she's saying i mean it's confusing and
and it's it's that's part is almost kind
of frustrating i mean survivor i i said
in the beginning survivor is strategy
plus luck and you you've got to have
both of those um but it's it's
frustrating such a fast-paced game to
also have so many
swirling things going around you where
it
it becomes a little bit russian roulette
like i said before and so i think that's
really what makes it so hard is that
you're in these small tribes trying to
grab on and then it just ripped from you
and so it becomes a little just kind of
chaotic and you saw that last night with
tiffany being like what is going on
honestly i would be tiff i'm going to be
honest with you it would just like it's
not here i'm dehydrated i get where she
was coming from um i wanted to ask you
too you know this
is such a crazy game
and we've only seen such a small portion
of it but based on what you've seen and
you've watched at home and also from
your time on the island i'm gonna ask
you a two-part question first of all who
would you like to win who would you like
to win this season of survivor first of
all let's start there
uh from the whole from from anyone or
from it can be anyone anyone you've
liked their game or even your i know you
guys are really close on yasa so it
could be someone from yasa personally
i'm an f fan
that's my choice but it's art because
there are so many great people you know
honestly tiffany um i know people think
that we had it out but tiffany is a ball
of energy like i said she was my aqua
dog partner we would um she was also we
called each other island husband island
wife we would sleep next to each other
sometimes people you know i was actually
a little worried about the optics of
that you know are people gonna think
we're too close but you know she just
she's been through so much with her
story which is who she is and honestly
she's just
such a positive person such a person
that when you're talking to her you
instantly like have a connection with
her and she just makes you feel so good
so happy and so um yeah rooting for her
oh i love that and honestly that makes
me feel so good because i feel like the
edit made it seem like you guys were
going like this
um we were really and honestly that may
have also been some of the uh despair is
that like you know you had two people
that you know we've really enjoyed each
other and had so much fun together
oh this
ah breaks my heart um i also wanted to
ask you who do you feel deserves to win
this game so based on what you've seen
thus far from all of the tribes or even
just on yasa since you are you know an
expert on that uh do you have someone
who you think who has played the game
really well thus far
um
i cannot say anyone on chaos deserves to
win um because i'm sorry but you know
some people may say what about xander i
mean going and telling everyone about
the advantages no absolutely not i mean
clearly they don't know what they're
doing in terms of who they're voting for
and i like i say i love them to death
but come on it's not all about strategy
it's not all about you know everything
but
seriously um i would have to say you
know just what little interactions of
challenges i had with like brad and
jeannie those are genuine people salted
the other type of people who i just love
their character their outlook in life
and
you know the whole cast is was amazing
but brad and jeannie just really stuck
out to me as people who just genuine
people that i that i just
love to watch